donc c'est cette cette caméra donc c'est
le moment où le monde à notre invité
nous emmener dans un moment intime et
j'ai commencé en vous demander une
nouvelle de votre père ce que tous vont
se demande et j'ai envie de savoir parce
que j'ai lu dans les journaux que quand
même quand vous êtes arrivé là-bas à los
angeles vous avez fait comme on dit le
ménage
bien que vous avez un entourage bah je
suis un peu maniaque moi j'aime bien le
ménage j'aime bien quand tout est bon
alors ça sert à quoi
oui oui non en fait oui c'est vrai c'est
pas vrai c'est à dire qu'ils ont ils se
sont amusés à dire que j'avais virer
tout le monde je pense pas non non j'ai
viré personne en fait ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'étais saisir le le personnel
et dire que voilà on allait limiter
l'accès à la chambre voilà c'est tout
parce que vous dit vous n'êtes pas très
fan de l'entourage de repères abondons
j'ai jamais dit ça disons que son
entourage n'est pas le mien voilà mais
ça veut pas dire que bon je le côtoie
quand je le vois et tout on n'a pas de
problème entre nous mais mais ça ce sont
des moments de quand même assez spéciaux
où je trouve que voilà même au nom de
l'amitié je trouvais que c'était des
choses qui vais rester familial voilà
est-ce qu'il ya un souvenir qu'on a
partagé quand on était gosses qui
revient en tête non non on n'espère
c'est un peu un voire deux ans donc gt
gt gt sur il a eu un petit peu il s'est
réveillé de il retombe toujours sur ses
pattes donc c'est vrai que j'avais
je pensais qu'ils allaient s'en sortir
toute manière parce qu'il est costaud et
puis bon on pense on pense pas on pense
plutôt à l'avenir on pense à ce qui va
se présenter par le passé généralement
dans ces moments là c'est plutôt un qui
peut on vit le moment présent on pense
pas trop à ce genre de chose quand on
pense au passé c'est généralement quand
les choses se passent mal donc là ce
n'était pas le cas il pouvait garder des
moments parce que moi que de
reconstruire votre biogée élire sont des
moments extraordinaires vous êtes gamin
quand même votre père vous vous
réveillez pour que vous jouer de la
batterie pour ses potes et ses pattes
c'est pas n'importe qui ça je trouve ça
assez extraordinaire sa part le jimi
hendrix mais je ne savais pas à l'époque
signe c'est con parce que j'aurais
peut-être très très mal joué si j'avais
su que c'était lui on se retrouve un
jour elle a quel âge il paraît ouais je
sais pas j'avais 6 ans et sur 6
septembre pour jimi hendrix visiblement
et ses skis et c'est ce qui m'a raconté
ouais on avait le mec comme bob dylan à
la maison comme ça moi j'étais super
content de jouer à 5 heures du matin moi
c'était mon truc ça fait moins plaisir
aux voisins mais moi j'ai été
c'est très content avec votre carte iba
ça c'est un dieu sait à quelle heure il
sait qu'un bail et je pense qu'il est
fait pour ça ouais il m'a vu jouer de
trois fois la batterie en studio mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'il est
nécessairement car il veut une batterie
pour noël il va
il aime bien il faut que je le mette sur
mes genoux pour pour conduire ils aiment
tous les trucs
donc c'est un petit peu c'est la csu
j'ai deux filles
sont plus grandes mais là un fils aussi
c'est vrai que c'est c'est super
différents et
je me vois son âge qu'on aime c'est
assez rigolo
[Musique]